hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and in this video i'm going to share
with you and i'm going to reveal the
steps and the secrets because believe me
this is a secret that you will not hear
this in school you will not even
generally find this online or on other
youtube videos i'm going to share with
you how you can become a millionaire by
age 25. now i actually did this i am a
millionaire i was a millionaire now i'm
a multi-millionaire my net worth is 20
million pounds i own this house i own
lots of houses i own a castle in
worcestershire and i became a
millionaire at age 25 and most of the
things that you will learn about on
other youtube channels and at school and
reading books where they're talking
about how to become wealthy how to
become financially independent i think
it's absolute garbage and nonsense
they'll say things like you need to save
more uh save money by not drinking
starbucks and not cancel netflix and
save up and then invest that money and
it's just rubbish here's how you're
going to become a millionaire you want
to become a millionaire by by the age of
25 now maybe you're already over 25 but
you want to become a millionaire for
years here's how you can do it you're
going to do it through business
through business
okay now property investment can't be a
business but you need to understand how
the business needs to be structured let
me tell you something if you've got a
business even if your business is making
a million pounds a year profit if that
business does not function without you
in it then your business is worth
nothing
if you've got a business and you're
making a million pounds a year but
you're having to slave away on that
business and work in it even if you've
got members of staff if you're working
in it then it's not a business it's a
well-paid job and a job is not valued at
anything so the first thing you need to
do if you want to be a millionaire is
you need to understand how a business is
valued a business is valued when it's
systemized when it functions without you
and where you can make a passive income
through the business now this business
can be a property business you can buy
houses or you can just do something like
i did which is package and sell deals if
you're packaging deals and selling them
okay just catch this because you can do
this right now if you have a freaking
pulse and are living in a wealthy
country like the america or like the uk
okay then can you find property
investments okay not can you buy them
not do you have the money to be able to
can you find them and the answer is yes
yes you can if you learn and put some
time aside you can find investments next
can you find people that have got money
that want to invest in property and the
answer is yes you go to the networking
events you learn what to say yes you can
so if you do what i did which is find
investments and then find investors and
just bring the two together and charge a
finder's fee in the middle
typically you'll get two percent of the
purchase price average house
250 grand you're talking five thousand
pounds
five thousand pounds just for finding an
investor finding an investment and
bringing the two together five thousand
pounds if you can do that
literally just twice a month
that's 10 grand a month
that's a 120 grand a year
120 grand a year that it means that if
you had systemized that business
okay that's a million pound business
right there how long will it take you to
to to be able to do this a couple times
a month and systemize it
employ somebody replace yourself
making them having a million pound
business is not difficult folks and if
you have a million business you're a
millionaire so first thing you need to
work harder on yourself than you do on
your job second thing you need to learn
how to systemize a business everything
you do you should write down and turn
that into an operational manual and
replace yourself constantly number three
you need to get really good at your
craft stop thinking about making a quick
paycheck and trading your time for money
and start thinking about how to become a
millionaire i believe if i can do it i
started absolutely nothing um and at 17
years old i i went on the mission and
the quest to become wealthy by 25 i was
a millionaire if i can do it i believe
you can too if you've got questions you
want more information you want more free
videos like this on youtube then let me
know you enjoyed the video by smacking
the like button and if this video gets a
lot of likes i'll make more like it
thanks so much i'll see you next time
[Music]